all right welcome back
I have been reviewing some some my old
Eclipse oh [ __ ] Oh
then this game leaves me for five
seconds I'm already well what the hell
what the [ __ ] did you come from you
weren't out here when they left the game
oh Jesus Christ
ah I've been reviewing somewhere lost
clips and I went down there and AH it
was probably one of the most scariest
thing I ever done and I do apologize
that I I realized I I was so into it you
know I didn't really say much and I can
I don't know we maybe wasn't
entertaining for you to watch either way
I try I'm gonna try to be you know more
active this time and try to be less
scared I don't know how that's even
possible but Jesus Christ and
I heard that there's gonna be even more
scary parts and I never ever thought it
was going to be more scarier than that
so yeah we got our parts so hopefully we
can fix the elevator now in the machine
room or whatever it's over here
it's locked so we're going to use one of
these
I cannot use it that way what about that
don't [ __ ] tell me I have to go down
there again I'm not I'm not going there
again
never ever it doesn't even matter if my
[ __ ] eye
it's not no no no no no no I'm not I'm
not going down there yet that's not weak
let's see here find the key that unlocks
the door uh-huh
find a way to start engine that powers
elevator uh-huh I guess we could check
upstairs
I am pretty sure I'm done down there
let's see what's up here
there's one room right two rooms maybe
even thought there's two rooms that's
mean means more [ __ ] adventures to
explorers and study or
guest room guests
he returned the teacup to the saucer and
picked up the Orbis one would an apple
and powdered on the strange happenings
all right
my journals
that was it
all right
[ __ ] cockroaches
oh that's nice
definitely more well-lit up here but
that usually means winds can
did I describe that that's pretty funny
all right yeah we haven't seen a living
soul the entire well I hope it's not
living
second of July 1839 I received a letter
today from the Algerian governor's
office disclosing the fate of Herbert's
expedition
a week after my departure
one of the men travelling with us
returned from the desert it was badly
injured as if made by a lion
the man rambled the lira only about I
know it said AG attacked by something
Horeb I've seen there too many times the
previous match the search party to look
for the expedition after searching for
days they found the camp abandoned
without any trace of Herbert or his men
tomorrow I'll retrieve the things they
recovered from Herbert tent at the
Customs House I don't know what to make
yeah
actually actually I was like I only seen
a glimpse of the monster and I think
it's in here you actually can see how he
looks without you know because otherwise
all the times it's been like so dark
so I haven't really catched a glimpse on
Dean
yeah third of July I'd sure if I wasn't
nine today I picked up Herbert's things
at the customs house they dug through
the trove of documents he had carried
found a rock detailing the expedition
sound the nature of this test ranged
from quick notes to colorful account of
transpired event
I skimmed the pages trying to figure out
what might have happened
may 17th the day I was trapped inside
the orb chamber Herbert
dryly states recovered Daniel after one
hour of entrapment this confused me
greatly I was suffocating within minutes
how could I have lasted an hour I
continued reading the peculiar text
Herbert States his facts without
judgment or passion but suddenly I could
read frustration into his text he pushed
his men to investigate the underground
tomb an effort which seems to have
strained the minds of his men how sadly
spread through the ranks and Herbert had
to take some extreme measures to
continue he finally visits the chamber
himself where he retrieves the orb to
the surface his account confuses me
greatly if he has the all what are those
pieces in my drawing hello
Takizawa this war
ah I really hope I don't bump into the
monster here I think it's even worse
I know because I can't hide here like if
I sit [ __ ] cockroach [ __ ] up [ __ ]
oh Jesus
I guess I got to use the crowbar
oh that surely looks some enough
it'd be all right so we're gonna find
the key to fourth of July 1839 it's done
the orb is assembled I was awakened by
an exhausting nightmare shaking not
sweating I retired to the drawing room
and a cup of tea the relative ease his
latest fell across the table as I left
them but somehow I knew how it was
supposed to be I fetched the tile which
I prepared a [ __ ] in others together
a sum without fault I joined them
producing the orb
I remembered so clearly the tar proved
unnecessary it was pushed out from the
joining pieces as they merged on their
own with no adhesive the ancient stone
relic now rests on my table
it's a macula surface and perfect shape
could have been moulded by a factory
this is all too strange oh geez why
don't you let yourself into
oh [ __ ] don't tell me have to go in here
no no no
No
I knew I knew it I [ __ ] would oh
Jesus Christ oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
I [ __ ]
Oh
I want to bounce Niq out you know
I want to get a girl inside now had seen
him yet
venters Katie
I am I am a [ __ ] I know that
and now he uses the door
it's gonna be dark when I open this I'm
pretty sure
oh Jesus Christ
d Sasaki Christ
huh
as I said earlier this game is gonna
give me a heart attack
oh Jesus Christ I was scary
but I was kind of ready for it though
that I needed definitely near that so I
guess we're done here I mean we got the
crowbar right no we can't do that
anymore
what do you we get we got our standard
read about it I get I guess that's good
I'm just gonna make sure I collected
everything it's pretty annoying if you
go through this and don't get all the
stuff you want that monster seems to get
closer and closer and closer
and I can't say I'm a big fan of that
I'm glad open this closet though [ __ ]
alright let's head back
sir Whelan Smith had been marked there
was no way for him to know that the
young man from the other day class such
a terrible shadow
all right
what the [ __ ]
did he leave it there
with this
Jesus
or the de Bloods go
I guess this is the next part [ __ ] the
strange letter frighten him but it was
also the only one which offered some
comfort
that's a dead hat why not
left four or five
five dead I mean oh well this doesn't
look scary
at least I have my lantern now I don't
have much oil though
so let's use our Kenda boxes a fun one
seriously when this game is done
I'm gonna be so filled with joy you know
what [ __ ] that song
why not
that's going in there
you